しゃちょーはでもね、何処でもすごい有名だよ
マスクしよ？マスクしてよ！
マスク...無くしちゃったんです
ああ、じゃ行こう！
劇団スカッシュさんの企画で
今ちょっと日本の
あらゆる場所をね
転々としているわけなんですけども！
すごい転々として本当に
頭がおかしい企画なのよ！
俺の弟っ！
47都道府県を
ビンゴで引いた所に行かなきゃいけないという
わりとメチャクチャな企画をしてて
それの場所の一つとして
今ちょっと茨城県の方に来てます！
多分、皆さんもご存知だと思うんですけども
僕は普段、静岡に住んでて
何かある度に確実に東京に行ってる、って言う
東京 or 静岡みたいなとこがあって
あんまり他の県とか
他の場所に行くことがないんすよ
ないんだね？ほんとにないの？
本当になくて
ホントに今回すごいありがたい機会を頂いたわけなんですよ
普段、いけない場所に行けてね
もう、お涙お涙でございますよ！
アハハッハ！
み、見えてないよ！
一度も涙見えてない！
他の YouTuber からすると
言われるんすよ！何か
大物 YouTuber とか！
有名とか！
こう、色々言われるんですけども！
それは、あくまでネットの指標じゃないですか
数字ってだけの
僕はなんか....
そんな事言われて実際有名じゃなかったら...嫌、です
まっ、恥ずかしい
恥ずかしいっす
イケてるみたいになっちゃうんで
ちょっとイケてる所もあるんでしょ？
まあ、ぶっちゃけちょっとイケてます。
アハハハハ
イケてる所もあるんですけども
静岡で、はじめしゃちょー見ても分かるじゃないですか？
まあ、それは
はじめしゃちょーかもっ？しゃちょ！みたいな？
東京で、はじめしゃちょーを見ても
はじめしゃちょーかも？！みたいになる
こういうちょっと
はじめしゃちょーが
来ないような場所で
ふと、はじめしょちょーが現れたら！
どうなるのか？
そう！どうなるか？
果たしてあの
皆がはじめしゃちょーを知ってるのか？とかをね？
あそこ見て！あの
この、ガラスのちょっとロード
二人で歩いてあそこの奥まで行って！
はい！
戻ってくるだけで！
どのぐらいしゃちょーが声をかけられるか！
確かに、確かに！確かに
それで良くない？？
そうですね、ちょっとそこら辺でやりましょう！
では、行ってみますか
どうなんですかね？
でもね、しゃちょー背が高いだろ？
皆さんも！あの
もし、しょちょー
背が高い人いるな～って思ったら ほぼしゃちょー だから！
あはははは！アバウト
あー！！！ヤバいヤバい！
一秒なんだけど、こっち出てきたら一秒で！！
いやでも、ここからですよ
握手していただいてもいいですかー？
あ～！
頑張ってください、応援してますー
すげーよ
道ですからね！
道だから！ただの道だから
お疲れ様です！
頑張ってください！
かっこいい！！
たつやさんと僕でカウントしてきましょう！
そうしましょう。
もう３人！
５人！
もう５人
きゃー！
募金お願いします！
ほら、募金！募金！
あっ、ちょっと財布持ってないから後で！後で！後で！
20人ぐらい！
今20人！
20人ですよ
お疲れ様です！
お疲れ様です
２１？
こんにちは
嘘～！
えぇー！
そうなんあっ、ありがとうがざいます！
たまに
はい、あ、結構見てます！
あ、毎日見てる？
ツイッターフォローしました！
あ、ありがとうございます！
お疲れ様です
２５です
こんにちは！
え、ちょっと今、知名度調査を
あ、ありがとうございます
いやもう、全然そんなに
あ、ヤバいヤバい！！
こっちこっち！
早く早く！！
早く早く！
早く！早く！
なんで走ってくるの？？
うふふふ
やばいですよ？だって
あ、こっちだこっち！
いるいる！
バイバイ！
ヒカキンさーん！
ヒカキンさんじゃないぞ！！
すごーい
いたあれ！
あれですよ！
ねー、写真撮ってー！
ええー？
何か、現実見たよ。
どういうことですか？！
いや、でもありがたい事です！ほんとに
いやすごい
いや～、ほら見て見て！ほらやっぱあそこ、ずっといるもん
これ、もう明日死んでもいい
(笑い声)
はじめしゃちょーって知ってますか？